face à l'afflux de patients ces
dernières semaines à l'hôpital de
kairouan c'est à même les salles
d'attentes que sont pris en charge les
malades du co lead
ici comme dans l'ensemble du gouvernorat
on manque de tout les carences en
matériel en oxygène en lits et même en
personnel rendre le quotidien des
soignants toujours plus ardue et
dangereux une situation critique que
dénonce le corps médical
nous sommes fatigués épuisés c'est une
réalité on ne supporte plus de voir des
patients de mourir sous nos yeux et être
dans l'incapacité de leur venir en aide
ou de leur fournir de l'oxygène
cette situation n'est plus possible il y
a même un de mes collègues médecins qui
s'est fait agresser à cause de ça mais
nous concrètement d'où est ce qu'on peut
lui apporter de l'oxygène
si nous avions à l'hôpital de l'oxygène
inexploité je comprendrais mais là on a
rien ici et on se fait agresser et ça ce
n'est pas normal
le problème c'est que rien ne disponible
ici la seule chose que nous avons nous
l'avons déjà utilisé l'arrivée des
malades est trop importante jour après
jour le double voire le triple de notre
capacité d'accueil
la solution c'est le gouvernement qui
doit la trouver pas le personnel
soignant
car tous les jours on on reçoit de plus
en plus certains même arrivent dans un
état critique et en charrette c'est à se
demander si nous sommes en 2021
dans ce gouvernorat le taux de
positivité okogie 19 n'a fait que
grimper ces derniers mois passant de 40
% en mai à plus de 65% pour le mois de
juin
alors comment expliquer une telle
recrudescence des cas positifs dans
cette région pourtant épargné lors des
première et deuxième vague à l' agence
régionale de santé de kairouan malgré de
nombreuses mises en garde adressées au
ministère de la santé le docteur mohamed
drissi et son équipe sont à pied
d'oeuvre
objectif coordonner du mieux que
possible l'action du gouvernement et le
travail des personnels soignants sur le
terrain à genève à la misère on a vu que
la situation y voir une situation très
grave s'annonce mal et ça serait ensuite
à plusieurs
le dodo de vaccination était 2e en
allant marquer au niveau de vie le
nouveau les gens respectent le mal des
valeurs de santé
il ya trop de comblement au niveau de la
vie nous avions mais la sphère privée ne
s'arrête pas et se et pour ça on en a
déduit que dacia sera elle peut devenir
très gars même son de cloche du côté de
la mairie de kirwan face au nombre
croissant de décès le maire de la ville
a été contraint de développer des
partenariats financiers avec des
associations et organisations privées
pour pallier le manque de budget
nécessaire à la gestion des inhumations
un conduit au procès de région qui
commençait tout juste à sortir la tête
de l'eau après le confinement
généralisée de l'an dernier qui a
enfoncé encore viser la ville de
kairouan dans la précarité le jitter
la leur nom
nous finançons
se sont détériorées 7,7 cette année
pratiquement tous nos projets sont
arrêtés pour faire face à aux nouvelles
dépenses de protection de nos emplois et
surtout pour les animations parce que
côté animation nous sommes débordés il
ya beaucoup de demandes depuis ma main
avant la pandémie de de matériel de
moyens humains surtout et de médicaments
mais il n'y a pas de
deux réponses à ces six maintenant les
choses ont commencé à changer il ya une
direction à séraphine surtout de la part
des militaires qui ont installé à un
hôpital de campagne
face au risque de l'apparition d'un
variant brésiliens ou indiens en tunisie
le gouvernement a annoncé que d'autres
gouvernorats pourrait être également
confier dans les prochains jours